Salut ! Une énigme par jour pendant 32 jours, à l'intérieur du défi du Mental Vlog !
C'est une vraie poupée russe cette chaine !
Tous les jours je vous donne une énigme et je commence à chaque fois par vous donner la réponse à l'énigme d'hier.
Si vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme d'hier, foncez la voir avant !
Comment mettre 10 vaches dans 9 cases ?
Sachant qu'on peut mettre qu'un seul élément par case, et bien il suffit d'écrire une lettre dans chaque case.
D'écrire réellement "DIXVACHES".
Ça marche avec pleins de choses. Ça marche aussi avec 10 lapins, par exemple.
Hâte de voir le nombre de pouces en l'air dans la vidéo d'hier, pour voir la proportion de personnes qui avaient trouvé.
Et aujourd'hui, plus qu'une énigme, c'est de la survie, c'est parti !
Plus qu'un défi, plus qu'une énigme, cette quinzième vidéo sur cette série là, va peut-être vous sauver la vie un jour.
On ne sait pas !
Imaginez que vous êtes enfermé dans un labyrinthe
mais n'importe quel labyrinthe.
Peut-être le labyrinthe le plus grand du monde.
Peut-être un labyrinthe fait en béton
ou en végétal comme "Alice aux Pays des Merveilles"
ou le labyrinthe d'une pyramide.
Ça peut-être un tout petit, comme ça peut-être un très très grand !
Quelle technique vous allez pouvoir utiliser pour sortir à coup sur du labyrinthe ?
Quand je dis "sortir", ce n'est pas faire demi-tour et juste reprendre la sortie.
En trouvant une technique qui va vous permettre d'être sûr à 100% de traverser ce labyrinthe.
Une méthode et une seule méthode qui existe.
J'ai été voir sur Internet, elle est expliquée sur d'autres sites
n'allez pas la voir, attendez jusqu'à demain, ça vous permettra de laisser cogiter.
Et cette solution là, moi je l'avais trouvé tout seul. Donc c'est tout à fait possible de la trouver.
Vous pouvez faire un pseudo labyrinthe sur un papier pour voir si votre technique elle marche ou pas.
Et si vous vous rendez compte qu'elle fonctionne, vous pouvez mettre des indices dans les commentaires.
Ou alors écrire simplement: "Moi, c'est bon j'ai trouvé !"
Mais surtout un pouce en l'air pour qu'on voit le nombre de personnes qu'on réussi à sortir du labyrinthe !
Profitez bien du soleil !
Abonnez-vous avant de partir !
Et rendez-vous demain à 11H.
Ciao !